buenas noches a todos buenas tardes
es un gusto gracias a ted por esta
invitación y gracias a todos por estar
aquí presentes el día de hoy me gusta
mucho ver caras aquí conocidas en
general todo el público que nos está
viendo en las redes sociales y en
general a ted muchísimas gracias por la
invitación
pues bueno
esta plática de innovación
resulta una plática bastante importante
bastante interesante y en general me
gusta mucho es una plática que en lo
particular cuando la escogieron y
conocieron el tema me pareció un tema
bastante
innovador
pero antes que nada a mí me gustaría
platicar un poquito de qué es innovación
y enfocarlo un poquito al liderazgo
porque
porque en la innovación y el liderazgo
van de la mano uno y el otro no puede
existir innovación si no hay liderazgo y
no puede existir liderazgo si no hay
innovación
más adelante lo veremos
pero en especial yo quiero practicar les
de mi experiencia personal para mí que
es la innovación y que es lo que ha
sucedido en mi vida y cómo es que está
innovado en general
vamos a pasar unas presentaciones antes
de entrar al contenido
innovación en general
como lo dice peter es un proceso no un
proceso que ya existe y que deseamos que
mejore en lo general
aparte de eso sabemos que existen muchas
ideas pero siempre uno es el que brilla
como dicen por ahí nace la estrella
sin embargo empiezan los procesos de
equipo de colaboración y de procesos
y entre el marco del liderazgo porque es
tan importante en específico dentro del
proceso de innovación que posiblemente
ya dijeron mis colegas en toda la
plática por qué es tan importante el
liderazgo
el liderazgo no es más que pues un
proceso también de cómo puede ser un
buen líder y en lo general todo este
tiempo
van marcando pautas van marcando
procedentes y van marcando puntos
pero en específico puede pasar mucha
teoría que me gustaría pasarla de una
vez tenemos tiempo suficiente aquí es un
gran icono también lo particular me
gusta mucho es un referente para mí
y este señor realmente winston churchill
para mí es un precedente bastante
importante todo lo que hizo y los que lo
conocen lo lo podrán atender
aquí marcamos bastantes puntos
importantes de la innovación y en
especial me gustaría dedicarle ese
tiempo solamente a la parte teórica
para que podamos ir viendo
pero los próximos diez minutos que son
tiempo suficiente
les voy a explicar
10 puntos
10 puntos muy importantes
del por qué yo considero que se puede
llegar a tener éxito y se puede llegar a
ser un buen líder esto es un proceso
personal esto no viene en la teoría esto
es algo que no viene en los libros eso
sea lo que yo les puedo compartir
punto número uno
para ser un buen líder primero tienes
que haber sido derrotado
primero tienes que haber
estado consciente de haber tenido una
derrota
y una vez que haya sido derrotado hayas
adquirido algo muy importante humildad
si no existe humildad no tenemos nada si
el ego el peor de los males está con
nosotros no vamos a poder lograr nada la
humildad es la base fundamental de todo
por eso para mí la el punto número uno
es la más importante más importante que
es adquirir humildad mediante la derrota
a que somos gobernables ya que somos
ingobernables con que podemos y con que
no podemos
punto número dos que yo he vivido
es muy importante el creer
el poder creer en algo en alguien o en
una cosa o en alguien en especial es
fundamental el llegar a creer es lo más
importante y lo más importante llegar a
creer en uno mismo si no llegas a creer
en ti no vas a poder trascender a todo
lo demás así que lo más importante es
creer en ti
en ti mismo
el punto número 3
fundamental
la espiritualidad
creo que en la vida existen muchas más
razones y motivos por los cuales
conforme vas creciendo puede llegar a
creer he tenido la experiencia de estar
en los continentes en diferentes
continentes
y también irán en diferentes religiones
no importa en lo que creas o en lo que
sea pero sí es muy importante tener un
equilibrio y la parte espiritual es
fundamental si no tenemos una parte
espiritual
tenemos
un déficit un problema es fundamental
creer en algo
ok la espiritualidad marca un equilibrio
y marca un precedente importantísimo
cuarto
y un paso importantísimo hacer un
minucioso inventario de lo que somos
nosotros si nosotros no sabemos quiénes
somos no somos nada debemos de saber
quiénes somos antes de poder seguir ese
inventario solamente lo puede realizar
tú conscientemente de manera honesta
contigo mismo de manera honesta tienes
que ser una persona honesta si no eres
una persona honesta
no puedes avanzar y este inventario con
esto lo tienes que hacer contigo todos
los días de allá para acá
de allá para acá y de allá por
así que es muy importante ser una
persona honesta y hacer un inventario
todos los días yo por ejemplo que hago
todos los días todas las noches trato de
revisar mis pendientes del siguiente día
y en una hojita pongo por orden de
prioridades que debo de hacer que debe
de seguir aquí no le contesté y trato en
verdad de responder hasta el último
mensaje a todas las personas que me
escribieron y que tuvieron el tiempo de
hacerlo trató de hacer un inventario
pero alimentario más importante es un
inventario personal sacando este
inventario personal
así como hicimos el del diario vivir
vamos a hacer un inventario general de
todo lo que hacemos y de todo lo que
fuimos porque si una cosa es importante
es
la infancia e infancia es futuro
entonces hay que hacer un inventario
desde nuestra infancia hasta el día de
hoy y escribirlo escribirlo y escribirlo
el quinto es poner relación a ese
inventario si no él pone esa acción y
cada uno de ustedes no la conexión y yo
me lo pongo acción las cosas no suceden
si no ejecutamos las cosas de manera
correcta no sucede nada tenemos que
tener objetivos definidos acá page
tenemos que tener objetivos definidos a
corto mediano y largo plazo
siempre debemos de marcar los objetivos
y debemos de hacer una cosa
concentrarnos siempre van a haber
factores que nos distraen pum pum pum
pum pum pero el día que dejes que uno de
los factores que te distraen se caiga se
empiezan a caer como bolas en el aire
todos los demás ya no los vas a poder
detener es muy importante tomar el
control el control de las cosas de
manera positiva
para que ninguna de las demás cosas se
te empiece a caer
sexto
tres puntos importantes
debes de creer en algo omnipotente
omnipresente y omnisciente
si no crecen esas tres cosas
eres un ser completamente ególatra
no podemos ser un dios
ni pido que crean en dios siempre
sencillamente
son tres puntos importantes
omnipotente omnipresente y es ambiente
creamos en esas tres cosas que alguien
más lo puede hacer porque si no lo
hacemos de esa manera
nos va a derrotar el gran ego el ego es
la piedra en el zapato más grande que
puede tener el hombre
séptimo
debemos de crear un semillero
si no creamos un semillero esto no
funciona
porque si no creas al que viene atrás de
ti como el de donde yo vengo no produce
es lo siguiente y no siembras y no
cultivas y por lo tanto no se crean
nuevos innovadores nuevo líder de
líderes y nuevos empresarios y nuevos y
nuevas personas en general tenemos que
crear un semillero porque atrás de uno
viene el otro y atrás de mí también hay
otro y adelante de mí hay otro entonces
el semillero de las personas considero
que es lo más importante y debemos de
pasar el mensaje y también enseñar a los
demás qué es esto si no les enseñamos a
los demás si no pasamos el mensaje no
podemos crear nada
y aquí está
8º
es fundamental
que tomemos el control de las cosas
pero simplificarlo es muy importante a
mí me pasa mucho en lo personal la
verdad es que
y hago las cosas chiquitas grandotes
hago una cosa pequeñita muy grandota que
no tiene sentido se me meten problemas
yo solo por eso la octava para mí es una
cosa fundamental y es tener un
equilibrio emocional más o menos
hay que darle importancia a la parte
emocional y hay que estar medianamente
dentro de esta parte
digamos
centrados o tratar de estar centrados en
el equilibrio emocional
noveno hay que progresar
pero cómo vamos a progresar si no
tenemos una amplia solución de todo lo
que dijimos anteriormente
pues bueno la manera fundamental de
poder progresar es dar servicio a los
demás
si no se da servicio y no ayudas a los
demás no puede ser un líder
el ayudar es la parte fundamental de
todo ser humano si no ayudas a otros no
se produce el cambio porque es un cambio
mágico pero a la vez viene el otro
efecto
tienes que pedir ayuda si no pides ayuda
no puedes hacer nada la persona que no
pide ayuda es una persona reiteró que
piensa que puede con todo y que puede
con los demás si tú no tienes en mente y
hoy caminas
innovando y como un líder sin al menos
dos cerebros auxiliares que te vayan
orientando este es un tip personal ok si
no caminas con dos líderes a tu lado
que sean como dos anclas en las cuales
puedes dirigirte
porque no todo el tiempo pensamos
correctamente hay que estar pensando que
no siempre tenemos la razón y que
siempre que tenemos que actuar tenemos
que tener al menos dos opiniones
diferentes
y que son cerebros auxiliares hay que
pedir ayuda la ayuda es muy importante y
posiblemente por eso el primer punto es
el más importante el derrotar se para
poder pedir ayuda
el décimo
mejorar
pero no solamente vamos a mejorar
el crear y el dar estos 10 puntos
simplemente son para que mejoremos un
proceso
sin embargo viene lo más importante
yo no puedo pedirle a un país a un
presidente a una democracia a un sistema
a una sociedad
a una relación a un amigo o alguien que
mejore nuestra persona nosotros tenemos
que mejorar de aquí para allá no
pensemos que el mundo nos va a dar todo
y que va a mejorar que todo vaya para
acá porque estamos en un error muy grave
nosotros debemos de mejorar de aquí
hacia afuera
la parte más importante y la evolución
somos nosotros nosotros somos los que
debemos de marcar el cambio si nosotros
no somos pequeños constructores
innovadores creadores
progresistas o lo que vayamos a hacer no
esperemos que los demás lo cambien si
nosotros no nos damos a nuestros mismos
esos minutos a esos momentos no
esperemos que los demás nos los den
nosotros debemos de marcar el cambio de
adentro hacia afuera la cosa no viene de
afuera hacia adentro eso nunca va a
funcionar
siempre el cambio se produce de acá para
allá seamos creativos seamos innovadores
y siempre tengamos en mente una cosa que
se los digo de manera personal tres
proyectos alternos trabajemos en uno que
nos sostenga trabajemos en otro que sea
nuestro sueño y trabajamos en un tercero
que es un macroproyecto aunque sea el
proyecto que queramos no importa pero
trabajen siempre tres proyectos de
manera alterna tres proyectos es muy
importante
de esta manera espero poder haberles
dado
o compartido algo de mi poca experiencia
estoy muy agradecido en general con sus
minutos y les agradezco mucho este
tiempo que me dieron gracias por
acompañarme el día de hoy y le reitero
mi agradecimiento
[Aplausos]